penguins have long captured the
imagination and the hearts of people the
world over but while popular culture too
picks them as clumsy adorable birds with
endlessly abundant populations the truth
is that penguins are exceedingly
graceful often ornery and their
populations are in rapid freefall
the real-life situation is far more
precarious than people think and if
current trends do not change it may not
be long before penguins can only be
found in movies there are many things
about penguins that make them odd Birds
so to speak for one thing they are one
of the few bird species that cannot fly
having evolved from flight capable birds
about 60 million years ago surprisingly
their closest living relative is the
albatross a bird known for its enormous
wingspan and extraordinary soaring
abilities it may seem strange that
losing the ability to fly would be an
evolutionary advantage but the Penguins
short flipper like wings and solid bones
allow them to swim faster and dive
deeper than any other bird on earth
filling an ecological niche that no
other bird can penguins inhabit the
southern hemisphere being one of the few
bird species able to breed in the
coldest environments but contrary to
popular belief they are not restricted
to cold regions nor are there any at the
North Pole
in fact only four of the 18 penguin
species regularly live and breed in
Antarctica most penguins live in sub
temperate to temperate regions and the
galapagos penguin even lives and breeds
right near the equator off the coast of
South America they are also found in
South Africa Namibia Australia and New
Zealand as well as on a number of
islands in the southern Atlantic Pacific
Indian and Antarctic oceans
although penguins spend 75% of their
lives at sea they must come to shore
every year to reproduce and to molt
their feathers they do this in a variety
of places from the temporary ice sheets
of the Antarctic to the beaches of South
in Namibia to the rocky shores of
sub-antarctic islands to the craggy lava
surfaces in the Galapagos different
penguin species have different nesting
practices some dig burrows into dirt
sand or dry guano some nest and tussock
grasses some build nests out of small
rocks sticks and bones while others
don't build any nests at all although
most penguins lay a clutch of 2 eggs the
two largest species the king and the
emperor lay a single egg that they
incubate on top of their feet for
approximately two months
unfortunately 15 of the 18 penguin
species are currently listed as
threatened near threatened or endangered
by the International Union for
Conservation of Nature in the last
several decades we have seen the world
populations of most penguin species
decline by up to 90% with two of them
the yellow-eyed and Galapagos penguins
down to just a few thousand Birds
penguins are an indicator species the
proverbial canary in the coalmine simply
put if penguins are dying
it means our oceans are dying and sadly
most of this decline is attributable to
human activities historically penguins
have had to deal with multiple
disturbances the mass collection of
penguin eggs and the harvesting of the
seabird guano they nested in caused the
dramatic decline of several penguin
species if you're wondering what humans
would want with seabird poop it was used
as an ingredient in fertilizer and in
gunpowder being so valuable that in the
19th century it was known as white gold
current threats to penguins include the
destruction of both marine and
terrestrial habitats introduced
predators entrapment and fishing nets
and pollution from plastics and
chemicals
there have also been several large-scale
oil spills over the past 50 years that
have killed or impacted tens of
thousands of Penguins around the world
but the two major threats to penguins
today are global warming and overfishing
global warming impacts penguins in
multiple ways from interrupting the
production of krill due to decreased sea
ice formation in the Antarctic to
increasing the frequency and severity of
storms that destroy nests to shifting
the cold water currents carrying the
Penguins prey too far away from penguin
breeding and foraging grounds even
though humans may be the greatest threat
to penguins we are also their greatest
hope many research and conservation
projects are underway to protect penguin
habitats and restore vulnerable
populations with a little help from us
and some changes in the practices that
impact our planet and oceans there is
hope that our tuxedo clad friends will
still be around in the next century